on ne naît pas femme on en meurt sans
oui c'est non victimes
on te croit depuis quelques semaines ce
type de slogan s'affiche dans plusieurs
quartiers de la ville
ils sont l'oeuvre de collectifs de
collage féministe je pense qu'avec le
coc vide les gens ils ont le temps de se
renseigner de lire de s'activer de
s'énerver et il ya eu blackman l'ex
batteur il ya eu la deuxième vague de
mitu qui a été énorme et on a essayé de
vraiment se lier à ça pour crier pour
tous les gens qui sont énervés face à
ces situations là ce mouvement venus
d'europe se décline également sur les
réseaux sociaux mais procéder à ce type
d'affichage comporte des risques
en juillet elles ont reçu une
contravention de près de 2600 $
nous sommes qu'elles ont réussi à payer
grâce aux dons recueillis dans une
campagne de sociaux financement qui a
duré quelques jours c'est une somme
absolument colossal qu'on aurait préféré
remettre pour des associations qui en
ont besoin
la colle qui est fait avec de la farine
et de l'eau faut le savoir que en gros
on dit que cela peut durer trois mois en
collage puisse et des feuilles en papier
en soit ça s'enlève à la main on peut
l'arraché très facilement s'exprimer sur
les murs de la ville n'est pas une idée
nouvelle dans les mouvements féministes
de tout temps les mouvements féministes
ont se sont servis de la rue pour faire
entendre leurs revendications les
suffragettes évidemment nous viennent en
tête mais même avant en plus récemment
on pense à dollars 2 rue féministe donc
décollage par exemple aux états unis
autour de ce top sterling ouais mais
tous merle arrêter de dire aux femmes de
sourire
une façon de se réapproprier la rue qui
reste selon certains un espace
inégalitaire entre le harcèlement de rue
et le profilage racial par exemple mais
on a la preuve que tous les individus
tous les humains ne peuvent pas être
dans la rue de la même façon en
utilisant la ville comme babillard les
membres du collectif espère marquer les
esprits en amont les choses puis en les
mettant vraiment dans la rue peut-être
qu'on va réussir à la longue à
déconstruire les apprécions les venues
galles pics sont présents dans notre
société
depuis trop longtemps le spvm ne peut
souhaiter commenter le mouvement des
collages féministe de son côté
l'administration plantes se dit engagé à
lutter contre les violences et les
discriminations et par conséquent
sensibles au message fort que véhicule
le collectif artistique dans le cadre de
ses actions
cependant les invite à communiquer avec
les équipes de la ville pour discuter
ensemble de moyens de mettre de l'avant
leur art et leurs revendications en
respectant les règlements municipaux
ici la direction de charretier radio
canada montréal